you
hi everyone is cherry I'm on chess calm
and I just got paired up with Rodrigo 21
we're playing a 3-2 game let's go let's
go with D for okay let's see how this
plays out that seems very early to
deploy the bishop I'm going to maybe try
and take advantage of that b7 pun
like maybe right now with an immediate
exchange or queen let's go with an
exchange first queen bee three let's do
queen bee three right now while queen
bee six isn't an option so yeah you know
because if Knight c3 then there's c6
queen bee three queen bee six is a fine
reply but now it's a bit uncomfortable
to defend b7 okay that's definitely
something black doesn't want to have to
do what they did it okay so let's pile
up on this pawn here and Bishop f4
Bishop g5 I'm welcome with a dark square
Bishop exchange let's play here now yeah
let's go here a bit more aggressive so I
could be taking advantage let's trade
that's my bad Bishop any hope it can
maybe take advantage that a six square
these squares here d6 and d3 are good
spots four nights in these structures so
let's see if we could maybe maneuver a
night there at center stage let's go
here anticipating maybe a c5 break we
might end end up in a hanging pawn
structure let's get all my pieces
working a flight square at some stage
Bishop a6 can be annoying hmm can also
throw my
night in here queen is unprotected on c5
I have Queen a3 is it now time for a
flight square let me insert a flight
square move and yeah on c5 i think i
might go clean a three okay they're
doing similar and they're playing quick
hmm yeah let's do this I think that
could be a bit of a bother it's been
uncomfortable no [ __ ] of a six move
okay and maybe hmm I'm not sure I want
about a four a five is that too much
yeah I don't like my bishop there
anymore I'm not sure quite I want to be
and I want to play 95 but I'm fearful of
an undermining move with c5c for
structural change I have to be mindful
of that c5 c4 is at three verses 2 on
the queenside and that could be and
that's so nice ok let's go here pressure
on the night i have this covered and
maybe I'm making way for b4 b5 a
minority attack okay we're going for
this are we okay hmm to trade or not if
I trade I'm pulling that piece forward I
really want to do that we might have a
bunch of exchanges soon No okay I think
this position will soon be stripped to
just minor just a night each let's do
this that Bishop is actually a bit of a
pain I'm still fighting for something in
the form of okay that sacrifice won't
work on h3 still fighting for something
at playing against their pawn structure
is the main thing I'm just finding that
Bishop too much of a an annoyance so and
I don't know that I want to take because
I'm inviting this Knight to f5
and use one step away from here so now
I'm in a spot to do these moves let's
start first with rook c2 just preparing
to double your work see one I self queen
a6 I played my bishop there but let's
not forget about my queen maybe making
use of that square I have e4 and ce4
covered have to be very cautious of
structural changes this is the main one
the only one okay is this some idea
coming over here to attack me my night
has not yet committed himself to the
queenside he could come over here
defensive resources Knight f3 knight to
e5 I've not ruled out I think 95 okay
yeah let's do this first I want to get
in maybe a 3 B 4 are they going to play
83 that might that pond might be hunted
right down now if b5 this night would
want to be really quick to get to this
square but I'll Triana I'll try and make
that difficult okay that's what they're
gunning for hmm let's see okay let's go
here for starters in the 95 this has to
be pretty knowing i have no there's no
longer okay that's very weakening and
how can i take advantage of that let's
go here first maybe no a 3 and b 4 is
secure their queen is tied down hmm i
don't know how powerful my night would
be on d3 at this stage i gotta play
faster where is their night going not
sure let's back up here maybe the Queen
comes out on this diagonal yeah that
might be an idea my night on f4 I want
to get my night to d3 let's go here
they're tethered to the
defense of this pond the night cannot
move let's see hmm i wonder i think my
night on f4 would be good keeping
pressure on this pond okay this is all
the more appealing i get here with tempo
30 seconds yeah my night right here has
to be I would think a great bother I
don't know who would benefit with a
clean exchange depends on if this Oh
what is that move get the exchange you
know that's just a blunder there okay
now i'm i'm open to a queen exchange for
sure okay let's keep my queen really
active right here Queen c7 coming how do
I make that night move hmm ok let's go
here i'm prepared to sack back hmm I
break this down that's so easy let's go
here for starters hmm ok let's let's
throw in a check let's play here stay on
this diagonal living off of the
increment let's try this again that's a
nothing move let's get out of pins let's
see I want to I want two Shack back on
that c 6 square ok now i can because
their queen is unprotected to go here
they're clean is unprotected i miss that
probably resign at this point ok they
resigned yeah let me let me just go back
before i even look at this one with the
engine stockfish this is um is probably
just a too early case of the bishop
coming out to f5 because of this
can be seven square in this it's again
timely because if I play Knight c3
instead of Queen here right now so you
have to strike while the iron's hot on
this one a natural Knight c3 c6 queen
bee three one move later queen bee six
is fine so I think we'd be three right
away and this is already a great
concession to have to play b6 and weaken
these light squares because he's no
longer around you know it's a different
story if he's feeding cattle to remedy
these weekend squares with b6 but not
the case here I probably miss some other
stuff i'll be curious to know if there's
a great difference between Bishop to g5
or f4 and the other and there must have
been something around here I know I
could have done better I know this is
just a slow improving move h h 3 h 6 i
wonder if there's something else i could
have been going forward with a pitch of
a six in 95 on c5 there's night be five
but again i was a bit I've been
concerned about this c5c for stuff but
um yeah those are just some rough
thoughts I think it's a good idea to go
over the games without the engine
initially and then uh well let's see
what stock which has to say at this
point okay let's see where we can make
some adjustments here Bishop f5 c4e six
okay it likes to first take like i did
in Knight c3 okay queen bee three is
fine as well okay at this point it's
suggesting knight c6 mmm thats still I
think I'm still gaining something with
that it's not it's not too comfortable
to obstruct that sepan I guess the idea
would be on Queen takes b7 there's night
b4 yeah now I have to worry about c2 so
i guess instead of b6 in the game
there's knight c6 i can't really take
that pawn suggestion is now Knight c3
and
night before here well starts to get
pretty sharp doesn't it Withey 4d takes
and there's already night g5 stuff
against f7 and Bishop coming out that
got violent very quick okay gives us a
little bit of an idea so b6 can't really
be a fan of that and it's my suspicion
it's not too good pawn advantage already
with that move ok Knight c3 c4 alright
well instead of Bishop g5 there's
already e-form wow I didn't even
consider it it's already probably
winning at this point with the e4 and on
pawn takes Knight g5 still no 95 this is
too much Bishop e6 Bishop c4 just an
enormous amount of development here no
black pieces are out made is threatened
on s7 c7 or c6 is collapsing efore will
be scooped up this is an attack for free
this pawn will be one back Queen f6
apparently best Knight takes e4 can't go
in this direction ok well that's
actually very very good to know a good
way to take advantage of an early Bishop
f4 in conjunction with be six nights III
is not just an attack against d5 but
it's prepping this nice forward movie
for getting all you can out of that
central pawn in doing so with tempo
that's sharp ok well that's the way to
punish this I didn't do that we got into
much more positional territory and
really no advantage now this is I mean
I'm playing still for something playing
against the structure comparing the
white side white structure versus black
structure the white side is better but
is that really enough I don't think so
is getting some useful moves in as you
can see it's right around here mmm yeah
it's already pointing out Bishop to d3
instead I mean I eventually went there
as I wanted to play 95 let's have a look
at 95 I was fearful of this night be
five queen bee 8 yeah you see I don't I
don't have the a follow-up it still has
a slight edge but this is a bit of a
pain and if my bishop can be kicked out
I mean maybe these pawns start to get
rolling I don't know okay well and in
any event this is something you
certainly have to be aware of these this
is this is a very very big deal let's
say on here c5 I make just a nothing
move I don't know a three it's not
calling for c4 right now but just to
emphasize this is now three verses to my
bishop is interfering with getting this
majority working the a 6b five ideas but
you have to be cautious of this
transformation didn't happen in a game
and it just danced back and forth in a
very non-confrontational game for quite
a bit doubling up on that c6 pawn like
this was a little bit helpful to me so I
want to play be four so I did b3 just so
you know I could get in be four maybe
maybe b3 wasn't even needed because on a
44 when or if a 4 comes just making a
passing move on a 4 maybe I could just
go be4 and get that move in in one shot
anyhow a three well one thing to know
you wouldn't want to play a three to do
this because of the clamping down effect
a four so I want to
to threaten b5 at some stage so if I
allow if I allow this this beep on is
pretty much going to be the exchange for
the a pond as soon as that move happens
so be three we got beef or in any other
tactical shots missed a half pound
advantage it's tough to break down okay
it likes this idea of night to e1 and
it's running into a tempo is very
mysterious move right here that's where
they hung the exchange but what would I
have done if it's calling for brooke d 2
d 8 I mean this night is defending c6
and I don't know how to attack it with
my night and if I can't attack it with
my night then I don't know how to break
down this position hmm computer calls
for first what was popping up H for now
night f4 what is that really leading to
let's see Queen f7 huh it wants to sack
the exchange interesting rook takes
Knight takes rook takes and maybe if
challenged rook c5 ooh that is very cool
unrep takes probably this so now there's
the d4 square for the night and he will
be enormous right there well I guess
that's how you deal with a night that's
trying to defend the c6 pun another
piece will be required to defend here I
guess because there is this exchange
sacrifice in a super night ending up on
d4 on exchange rooks well if you are
going to exchange what looks you want to
get something out of it in this case
would be now a connected past pond and a
wonderful d for post okay that's cool
instead we had look there and while the
exchanges picked up anything wrong with
what I was doing I mean I was lacking a
plan for a couple of moves she's kind of
a harassing the black queen offering in
exchange I don't even know if that was
best one thing I can say is that if the
Queen's are exchanged let's just say
this happened
and black is coming over here to defend
the pond I'm now in a position to play
f3 I could think about this central
expansion because there's no fear of my
king getting checked like crazy so with
the Queen's off I could think about
opening files by way of E 4 or even g4
you know okay well black was wise to
keep the Queen's on the board I believe
but after a couple moves at some point
the queen is unprotected and then I had
this tactic of rook takes c6 and then
that was it okay well some interesting
things to take away for sure it's early
deployment with the bishop first
capturing queen bee three we saw knight
c6 is better and we also saw b6 can be
punished much more swiftly for sure of
course wasn't punished at all I got into
the position of waters big time but at
this point here this eve or move very
sharp and this is already collapsing for
black okay very cool as usual I hope you
got something out of this video feel
free to leave any comments in the
comments section below and I'll catch
you in the next one that's all for now
take care bye